so what I'm going to do right now is a
braid that looks normal but is actually
done with the ends tied there is no
practical reason why you would want to
do it this way but it's a bit of a
mathematical puzzle the idea of braiding
something with two fixed ends you start
by segmenting the hair into three pieces
then take two over to one side and loop
the bottom through the gap do three
braid motions as normal right into the
middle then left into the middle then
right into the middle work in groups of
three and after each three pass the
bottom through the gap on the side you
just finished with after every six braid
motions the bottom will untwist itself
it's another example of how some things
have symmetry under two rotations but
not under one the Smith medical fact
means you can keep braiding forever
without the bottom becoming tangled
after I've loosened it up it looks just
like a normal braid
thanks for watching and please subscribe
to my channel for more videos